hey we're here on overtime did the Saudi
King slight Obama by not coming to Camp
David this week that's right the Saudi
King was supposed to show up at his Gulf
Council Conclave and he snubbed us I say
good I say let's break up with Saudi
Arabia all together why can't we do that
actually my biggest fear about another
Jeb Bush in the White House is that one
of those pictures of a bush is holding
the Saudi princes hand and just knowing
that we're just marching straight well
to something all presidents have held
their hand held their hand but you know
what's happening right now it's time for
us to stop it is time to snub those
thugs
I remember articles in the 70s when I
was in college about how we have to get
off the oil with the cartoon of the oil
pump as a her epidermic needle that were
hooked on the oil member Jimmy Carter we
have to energy independence oh no but
that would require regulation and
government spending on infrastructure
and we can't have that aura aura I mean
an energy carbon tax that would be the
best the third thing attacks right we
can really have that but why don't we
tax bad ship that hurts us like oil
instead of good things that like work
that crazy is that a crazy idea
Pass yeah all right Heather which
candidate for president will have the
most aggressive anti-party poverty
agenda ah that's a very good question so
I think that Secretary Clinton actually
gets a bum rap on issues like these I
don't think that she is necessarily the
most progressive when it comes to
challenging corporate power but I think
when it comes to I mean her first job
was at the Children's Defense Fund right
when it comes to these issues of poverty
these kitchen-table economic issues I
think she's got a Crusaders heart on
this I actually do well I don't I did
about Crusaders hard but yes I agree I
think I don't worry about her on
domestic issues with the left I worry
about her being too right on foreign
policy that's where I worry about her is
that she's a kind of a hawk and I would
smattering of putting green I was wrong
oh yeah I on what is the status of
campus debate on Islamism whoa Wow yes
you know you were disinvited you were
supposed to speak good Brandeis I was
supposed to speak at Brandeis and I was
disinvited this year to be a better
fight with it beyond you know else yeah
we've all been disinvited yeah great in
fact like you've you've been disinvited
from America as a black
okay Nicholas all working right there
like yours on the top on the oven I just
got asked to be a commencement speech er
speak that's theirs host parade so funny
because you know you started out as the
person that I nobody wanted to be me I
got thrown out every school ever went to
you're like you're like Bill Clinton in
the 90s like he was the awful guy who
killed Vince Foster a blow job and that
as time goes by he's like the old
building of the old or he's respectable
now I know I'm totally right nobody ever
gets mad at I said you stick around long
enough and your respect you become an
Insider and yeah of an outsider
right anyway I'm sorry I think that we
should be worried about what's going on
in campuses and not all campuses but
students need to go to college to learn
how to think not what to think
if we don't give them a chance yeah
thank you
Brendan did you ever get there or would
that stick because I shamed them into
actually rescinding me banned and
actually letting me see I I think
Brandis has been punished enough and
it's it's it's a campus culture is this
whole thing about protecting minorities
against what against learning how to
think minority students trust minority
students right it's opening yeah it's so
patriarchal right it's so patronizing
it's patronizing and and I'm more
worried about that really
then about and I'm also worried about
radical Islam on campuses but I think if
students learn how to think they'll see
for themselves the difference between
the ideology of Sharia versus the
ideology of liberalism and they need to
be able to differentiate that when they
graduate then you don't have that child
what would you know about it
what would I what would I know all right
who is right about the trans-pacific
trade partnership Obama or Elizabeth
Warren yes the the liberal fight between
themselves got a little man this week
Obama said Elizabeth Warren was just
another politician and he called her
Elizabeth and then sherrod Brown the
Democratic senator from Ohio was like
hey Obama that's patronizing to use her
first name
and Obama was like hey I'm not on the
rag you are and
he didn't say but it did get a has to
paraphrase yeah does anybody understand
no Street II know I mean I I'm in favor
of free trade but uh aren't if I can
figure it out when I read the news
stories the rest what's in the thing
yeah so you say you do read the minister
oh I stopped after the first paragraph
it is it is very arcane it is a hard to
get into but I am in the effort the one
thing with a few things that almost all
economists I know of Anna left and right
agree is free trade as a win-win there's
no such thing as free trade like that's
just a slogan that's like saying the
death tax or something like that
clean coal exactly call um
there are traders are one with wood
right trade is great every we're trading
all the time we're trading barbs you and
I it's great I just for you it's just
weather what matters is the rules and
how you write them and frankly who gets
to write the rules and the problem has
always been with our version of free
trade that corporations in their lobbies
get to write the rules and it's cost
American jobs every single time and it's
not made life better in the
manufacturing countries where they're
you know dying in sweatshops it's so why
do you think Obama's so for it so I
actually think that there's a piece
about this about China that is
geopolitical that is not about you know
jobs and economics at home but like this
is actually about showing our biggest
competitor that we have relationships
with these nations in its area that's a
big piece of it that I don't think he
can sort of say and lead with but I
think that is a major piece maybe he had
to make this bargain to get the climate
deal with China
you know presidents do things behind
closed doors we don't know and sometimes
we're glad they do
the trade meets about something else in
my world right so does what so does
water for John how do you explain our
obsession with celebrity oh god I don't
know what I when I hitchhiked across the
country and everybody picked me up no
one asked about that no one said to me
if that even if they knew who I were or
anything it was so amazing nobody wanted
to talk about celebrity that's so you
know the people have a whole different
set of question in the media the media
always asked me about the guests on the
show people I run into asked me about
the issues or they talk about their
lives you know you at which I was much
more interested in hitchhiking I feel
like doing an interview in every car
right I wanted to hear what they had to
say right so it was amazing to me even
if they knew nobody said what's Johnny
Depp like you know they which in real
life in New York or LA they do I always
want to ask you what's Johnny actually
actually people ask me but Bill Marsh
like you know what do you say I say
basically I can tell I tell them the
same thing that we said to each other
after the first show oh yeah I thought
you were you are as much of an [ __ ]
as I thought Edward and you said to me
Penn you are as much of an [ __ ] as I
thought it would say was just love at
first sight yeah they wouldn't come look
charmers does George Stephanopoulos is
donation to the Clinton Foundation
compromise his journalistic integrity
honor if you heard the story George
Stephanopoulos gave 75 grand to the
Clinton Foundation and he had to
apologize I think this is preposterous
we gave a million doba I know but George
Stephanopoulos was the guy in the war
room with Clinton in 92 we know from the
get-go where his politic that were so he
gives to Clinton's charity so that they
fight AIDS and malaria in the third
world well I don't get it
I could I cannot get excited about this
I can't either it's ridiculous be one
thing if we didn't know where George
Stephanopoulos stood but we knew and we
and we somehow we're okay with the fact
that he's now in
Marshall newsman that's what we know but
with this guy more than most we have to
admit we know is in the tank ya know I
got his start in his career working for
couldn't okay Mike what do you say to
people who link crime and violence to
rap music after I say you're stupid
rap music hip-hop as a entity was
started in the late 60s early 70s bunch
of kids were in the burnt-out later spot
itself yeah I'm not issue company's guy
check this I think I know you had like
Jay and the others a lot later than none
I got you checking out it's going to be
a movie comes out called rump Rubble
Cannes so in the late 60s all these kids
that recount of the fallout kids of the
black nationalist movement civil rights
poor white people's movement when Puerto
Rican national as a movement they had
street gangs in New York in the Bronx
that we just essentially burnt out at
some point
very late sixties early seventies these
kids were like we're going to come up
with our own peace treaty came up with
their own peace treaty decided that we
aren't going to engage in violence well
what's the alternative to violence the
Zulu Nation was born out of that Afrika
Bambaataa cool hurt Google these I'm
telling you is way bigger than any of
the record you think now and the story
is way more interesting these kids they
were children got together in the park
stole public electricity which I
strongly support and decided to do part
jams as an alternative to violence so
hip hop is not wrapped hip hop is the
thing that houses rap graffiti
breakdancing and DJing and
entrepreneurship and what it did what it
did was give poor kids the opportunity
to organize as an alternative to
violence now fast-forward 40 years it
worked a lot of money came into it guys
bought big chains and tigers and lions
and bears and [ __ ]
we got off course but at our core
hip-hop every time you see a successful
rapper you're seeing a job creator in a
community jay-z has provided hundreds of
jobs over dozens of millionaires and
it's changed the economy in places that
it wouldn't be an outcast in Atlanta
personally change the economy in the
last 20 years so I would say that people
who say hip-hop is violence I would say
let's start with the real violence
starters let's start with the three
major Abrahamic religions and let's do
away with their books let's start with
governments and geo warn politics let's
do away with our leaders so after we get
down the violence scale all the things
that create real violence to get to
music it'll be easy to get your hottest
people a hip-hop want me to say anything
you talk [ __ ] about politics smoke weed
and date don't black women but but leg
wasn't rapper's delight'
in 1970 no that's the first rap where I
thought it was Carla Thomas yes Fran I
was rapping tonight but hip hop's
birthday is November the 12th 72 or 73
the official birthday is older than me
I remember the birthday this is my
daughter's birthday hey Ania but it um
it started way before then it just broke
people figured out how to sell it right
yeah it started it as an alternative to
violence
that's what disturbed me about Baltimore
when I got when I was on throw your
hands in the air not like I gently get
back to that they said hey like it's
just sports more hair Crips and bloods
have united with the bgf to kill cops
but on my timeline all my social media I
saw a gang member saying we're going to
be about peace we aren't warring with
each other anymore they didn't say
anything about killing cops they seemed
like it was the first time in my young
life that I saw gang members say since
1992 say we're going to invoke our own
peace treaty and what government should
have done is what we do when we go to a
foreign land get all the people who are
rebels it didn't sit them down together
and say let's do some truth and truth
and reconciliation
let's fix this thing from the ground up
and I think we need to start engaging
hip-hop and young people in that way and
I think things will change we'll see
you get the last word killer I love you
brother
and killer Mike is could you kill the
Mike the duck you laughs I guess you
kill okay thank you everybody thank you
paddle